a new study by Gallup shows that
people's faith in mainstream television
news is at an all-time low let's look at
some numbers on public faith in TV so
10% now 10 2% one out of 10 people say
they have a great deal of confidence in
TV news 8 percent say they have quite a
lot of confidence so what you can see
here is that starting in 1993 there has
just been a precipitous decline in the
amount of people that believe in
mainstream news something happened you
know they started this in 93 but so
there was a major drop to 93 to 94 I'm
not exactly sure you know what that
might have something to do with I wonder
is that OJ Simpson that's when cable
news really went nuts that was 1994 so
maybe it has something to do with that
when when cable news and mainstream news
got so sensational does any of this
surprise this seems good to me as an
online news guy this seems all good to
me because this is what I've been saying
forever and this is why I do what I do
because we can tell the truth here and
we don't have something in our ear with
a network executive telling us what to
say and teleprompters and all that so
are you guys on the on the bandwagon
here that this is this is all good this
is not surprising I'll tell you right
now my family and every other Asian
family loss of faith in 95 when CBS
fired Connie Chung okay they were they
were done they were out so but in all
seriousness in the last 20 years you're
right it is the expansion you know when
Al Gore invented the internet yes
the - yeah yeah and there was a he
opened up the dialogues were opened up
and so you don't have your middle-aged
white guy no fans you're not middle-aged
or white you know presenting you this
information that you're supposed to just
take take at face value someone can tell
you something and then you can go
elsewhere to recruit isms about it to
read other opinions differing opinions
to read arguments about it then form
your own and I think it's this new
generation of people that were raised
just to be a little skeptical of
Authority we're not going to just take
the broadcasts and newscasters at at
face value yeah do you
this is more because mainstream news
just sucks or because online news is
good or maybe you don't agree with both
and like I mean I don't think it's
surprising to anyone it's not news to
anyone it's news people don't trust
media I mean it's gone down a lot but as
far as the internet goes that hasn't
been very well trusted either I mean
it's not as low now I think finally the
TV news has dropped below the internet
right the Internet's never really been
incredibly high either and I mean as far
as newspapers goes that's been the
people that are high but yeah yeah I
mean like newspapers are the most
trusted but the amount of circulation of
like printing new newspapers and stuff
like people aren't doing that anymore
it's gone down so much though they
actually think it might not even be a
thing in five to ten years anymore yeah
so I really think the Internet is going
to be the biggest form of media and it's
I mean I know that there's a lot of
troll websites and there's a lot of
misinformation out there everybody knows
anyone can go and look a pedia and edit
and I think like part of that has kind
of made people more distrustful of the
Internet but I mean there are so many
different looks like out there that you
can go to that have you know research
and peer-reviewed articles it just takes
a little bit of work right so how do you
do that because there is so much that
that's what I think is the interesting
part you know you have three cable news
channels and one's working for the
Democratic Party one's working for the
Republican Party and I don't know what
CNN CNN still looking for the plane but
what what do you do because there's so
much and for me it's tough right yeah
it's true I mean when depending on what
the issue is I always read the differing
opinions as it was mentioned earlier and
I I guess I bounce it off of my own
moral compass right what do I believe
and what's important to me and then I
take from it what I will I mean unless
you are you implying that the
newscasters like you know whomever is
reading and on the evening news is
straight up lying to you they're all
owned by giant corporations selling hat
dollars say that's a very small group of
people that control pretty much 90% of
what you see yeah on the news so I mean
if you I've actually seen different
videos where people have lined up the
introduced that introductory segments to
different news shows and they all say
the same line
like for Easter they're like oh we're
happy this year like what like but like
everyone says the same thing at the same
time in the same year yeah and like and
I saw a video where a lot of these were
placed together so it's almost like
they're all scripted in a different way
and I didn't you know like that is
that's gonna shake your cup and it's a
lot because it's all planned out they're
all saying the same things and even
whenever they disagree you kind of
wonder was that planned like I don't
think there's necessarily like the
secret cabal of five guys that are
sitting in a room disseminating this
information because as Carl Sagan said
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence and I've no
evidence of that although it seems like
it but that's not evidence right seaming
is not evidence it's not a regulation oh
I wish Dave yeah but is there is there
anyone in the mainstream news that would
you watch you trust them I don't think
they're sitting there lying like I don't
think people are necessarily like
automat no sometimes they do for sure I
mean you watch Chris Matthews on MSNBC
he said every opinion about everything
and and discounts what he says the week
before constantly so I guess some of
them are lying but the rest of them I
think are just a lot of them bird
they're just TV people who hand someone
hands in something and they read it is
there anyone that you watch that you
really in mainstream news that you watch
that you really feel like is telling
absolutely not yeah no I get all my
information from the internet and if
it's something that seems sketchy to me
I'll definitely look further into it
yeah you know I use more than one source
and TV just does not seem like something
that I would ever want to use crazy one
source geez something else she doesn't
have faith in okay we all know I missing
Cooper he is he's a good interviewer and
I don't think he's necessarily
presenting information I think he's just
asking the hard questions with regards
to whoever is prominent in the media but
I was take my news of the green assault
I was gonna say I like Diane Sawyer I
like everyone The Good Morning America
team because they're fun you know and
and they're generally pretty light hard
if I want something serious hitting you
know something I will I will turn to
more credible like online newspaper or
something with
investigative angle and by the way if
you want an example of what you were
talking about about how it seems like
they're all doing this in cahoots with
each other you know net neutrality which
we and the Young Turks talked about
constantly which is really basically
pretty much after the NSA it's the most
important thing that's happening in the
country right now because we need equal
access to the Internet so that these
giant corporations can't start
throttling what you can and can't watch
the network news and even Caitlyn's
barely covered it at all we covered it
here because it's important to us but
that's the whole point because
eventually they could start slowing it
down for us and then you'd only get your
information from the very same people
who aren't covering first there's so
many times I see something huge going on
you know somebody being you know
persecuted in another country for their
lack of beliefs or different beliefs and
that's never on the news the only time I
ever get that information is because
it's you know something that all my
friends are posting about on Twitter or
you know it's like the information that
I find to be incredibly important a lot
of times is nowhere to be found on the
news happened to remember maybe one of
these guys remember also when the whole
thing was happening in Egypt in Tahrir
Square and and we were showing what CNN
all day was showing that [ __ ] trial
does anyone remember what trial that was
anyone there was some stoop another just
some trial and other trial so the matter
historia so I think you know a woman who
was a woman that I'm sure killed
somebody or something something CNN was
literally showing the trial there is
nothing more drivel as' and my new show
based than showing eight hours of a
trial and CNN was showing Tahrir Square
in a little box while they were showing
the trial and nothing happens in a trial
do all day long and it's all [ __ ]
anyway anywho I hope you learned a
little something here and that you felt
we were being honest cuz that's what
we're trying to do